let's get into this video
it's got a lot of news coverage a lot of
press
and they're trying to give our brother
habib a hard time because of some
statements that he made let's go ahead
and listen to this video
and it's in russian but then it has the
subtitles but for those people who have
a hard time
reading
because english is not their first or
second language they understand a little
bit but we'll go ahead and but
definitely they can't read the english
language i'll go ahead and translate for
them or i'll go ahead and read it out
and then uh we'll go ahead and
uh
react to this
defend anybody marine girls are the most
useless people in the martial arts
[Music]
i think you
see
foreign
these people are passing by and showing
people that it is the second round
okay so
now it's very important because now you
got people who kind of just join the
bandwagon of bashing so they don't
really even dissect these things a
little bit
more carefully but anybody who's
on any level of trying to be a god
conscious person
who's a christian who's a jew
you know somebody who has some some
some level of
consciousness of the creator you know
they want to live a morally upright life
and maybe they want to enjoy let's say
some entertainment but i mean what he's
pointing out is if somebody's coming to
watch the fight somebody holding up a
poster to tell what round is it it is
it's very uncomfortable to see a woman
in her underwear up there so what's the
point it brings nothing to the martial
art it's just something that now entices
the man and it's another form of
attracting people to get more money
so it's very sad that nowadays you don't
have
people who will go ahead and
look at this as an oppression of women
to look at this as look i mean we know
in islam islam liberates the women so
you have women now who are putting on
more rather than less because they want
to be respected for their minds for
their intellect so these women now who
are out there when
and he's correct it's kind of a useless
profession what happens if you really
want to get down to the nitty-gritty it
can be very hurtful for these women but
it should cause us to think
because now you're selling your body
you're selling your soul which it leads
down to for the what for the pleasure of
men and what happens is you are your
mind is constructed to think a certain
way because of society because
of a big industry and all of these
things these social pressures lead these
poor girls into making these decisions
and now they're not you know a lot of
times you think when someone puts on the
hijab for instance everybody's quick to
say oh she was brainwashed
oh
she was manipulated but what at a global
scale
at a bigger scale how the industry where
you have girls young women
who will put themselves on display you
know to keep their figures they'll eat
food and they'll throw up food and
they'll starve themselves you know to
have a certain physique and they'll be
develop mental disorders and the list
goes on and none of them are happy
because of this and then what happens
dana white of course is enjoying this
and the men because now they can pass
these women along the fighters go ahead
and probably have their play with them
or some of these other big shots and
they get used and abused and at the end
they're scarred
you know and we want the best for these
women and all women so if you're a ring
girl watching this
hopefully this can penetrate the heart
and what habib said you're not going to
get angry with habib you're going to
actually think like wow
he's onto something it's not like a
cognitive dissonance and you stop and
you're just thinking like oh man this
guy's like backwards he's no no he's
forward he's actually forward thinking
what happens is when you bring on the
human being the woman and you expose her
in her underwear i mean this is backward
this is something now that's oppressive
so just think
think and again if you're a christian if
you're a jew if you're a god-conscious
person you know this already there's not
much to talk about but if you're
somebody who's just a hedonist somebody
who's just living the life of debauchery
you don't care you're just trying you're
addicted to porn you know when you
that's like your
day's highlight is just looking at women
who are naked and of course this is
going to get in your way but you know
also deep down inside that this is wrong
so actually khabib is helping these
women to think you know at first the
medicine when it goes in or when you
taste it it doesn't taste too good so
he's speaking his i mean freedom of
speech to speak his mind and he's
getting a lot of heat for it but now
just think
think of the message behind it really
think a little deeper and we gave you
some things to reflect and think over
would jesus approve of this would moses
approve of this with the greatest men
that walk the earth these messengers of
god almighty sent and the last and final
message of prophet muhammad peace and
blessings be upon i know this is heavy
on some people but this is
truth and the truth shall set you free
and we have to think what's our purpose
in life why are we here is it just to be
entertained is it to watch naked women
is it to watch naked men you know is it
just to fulfill our lusts and desires or
is there more right because the fight
just like the fight i mean if you put
two people in a cage and there wasn't a
goal there wasn't a purpose that
wouldn't make sense would it what about
this life there is a purpose you have to
find your purpose you want to know your
purpose ask that one who created us for
a noble purpose the creator that happens
on earth so before i get too preachy and
teachy i just want to go ahead and thank
habib
for
speaking the truth and the people out
there just to remind them if they're
jewish christians or people who really
want to live a morally upright life you
know really dissect this and look at it
not just from the superficial what the
media puts on there and we have to
combat this
because we can't let these big
industries and much of the social
pressure of hedonists and people who
really don't have any moral compass
moral values dictate the way for our
lives for our families for our futures
so this is out of the love that we go
ahead and share this thank you very much
and we started with peace we end with
peace peace be with you jesus
don't forget to go ahead and subscribe
right now hit that notification bell so
we can get more of these messages these
good messages out for the world hope you
enjoyed peace be with you assalamu